there are way to do this so it doesn't
hurt no beauty is paint
boy Georgia has really suffer Missy I
need a moment with page make quick I'm
only I'm beautiful
yeah I'm listening to what to you I'm
not saying anything well if you wanted
to say anything I'd be listening but I
don't want to say anything and I don't
want to be listening but here we are are
you feeling better yet you're being
weird
hmm not in the usual way because that's
my life now what do you mean everyone is
acting weird my mom is going on dates
and my dad is acting like a child
my sister's crying all the time I just
wish that everything could go back to
the way it was I don't think
it turned out I was really good at
listening the trick is to sit there and
when you want to leave don't I have to
live in two separate houses and my
grandma's has the meanest things about
my dad I know everyone is upset that I'm
not doing well in school it's just hard
to care
everything that used to seem important
to me just
does an enigma
so I guess
really I just feel alone
that sounds hard
it is dr. Sturgis was right there was
nothing I could do to fix this or so I
thought
can I offer you a hot beverage
that would be nice be right back
the hot beverage of comfort would become
my go-to method of dealing with someone
in emotional distress and it always
worked except when my wife was in labor
where was suggested I throw it in my own
face
what's doing pagers feeling sad so I'm
making her a hot beverage no you're a
good kid
I'm proud of you thank you of all my
accomplishments I don't know why he
singled this moment out but I'm glad he
did
[Music]
just havin you
[Music]
[Applause]
submission is
[Music]